hello guys my name is Ryan right
I'm Jerry listen guys I'm gonna be going
out of town this weekend whoa it's
Veronica's birthday 46 years old she's
sorry but what is her seat it's red it's
her birthday and taking her on a trip
her and her family a couple of things I
we posted a video about you guys
submitting your sketches and short films
I'm gonna start posting that next week
it's going to be one of the very first
uploads so I said I'd be posting them
weekly so yes those will be there when
we react and review them and uh and I
already made the other announcement so
the two things have been said we're
gonna watch the 10 Cloverfield Lane
official trailer numero uno yeah
starring John a good man yeah bad robot
dropped this late last night looking JJ
what mary elizabeth winstead [ __ ] JJ
his promotional efforts yeah I mean I
generally like the way he promotes I'm
hoping this is um you know like
mysterious but doesn't give away too
much but still intrigues me enough to
watch the movie that's what I've heard
I mean pretty much everyone has looked
at this trail everybody I sort of
follows look to the trailer been like
okay good don't show me anything else
because I want to see it like yeah like
something along the lines of the Batman
versus Superman trailer back o topical
humor waylaid me on some skin let's
watch this finally people everyone shut
your [ __ ] mouth we should turn on
those lights there's a glare here
because of these professional lights
thank you
totally different
my
things
ha damn something's coming
uh-huh
listen I haven't done this in a while
oh no am I gonna yeah all right Erica
you gonna use the front of your hand
okay nipple chill I feel that nipple
your shelves raised it is really raised
other nipple I give this to nipple
shields usually just one two nipple
chills me I'm there yeah that's awesome
there's an awesome trailer I mean I
don't know exactly exactly how that
movie's gonna play out but I want to see
it I like the concept of like it's John
Goodman from what I'm gathering John
Gibbon knows there's some [ __ ] going on
outside yeah and then it's domestic
sounds like the one woman I can't tell
we can't tell what exactly they're like
you can't tell what they're
knowledgeable about and what they're not
knowledgeable about we add and and what
their circumstances are like yeah it
almost life is like it's a deadness kids
maybe but then HP then it could just be
three strangers living together and then
the guy jog them it goes a little bit
crazy you know from having to stay like
contained in this one home that's what
that's the vibe I'm getting is these
guys are containing this one home while
the [ __ ] apocalypse is going on
outside
you know that's from the past no more
serious well yeah they're in a bunker
like there yeah I doubt that is you know
like a shelter of some kind I gotta say
um at first I was like oh this isn't
handheld this isn't some found-footage
stuff yeah but they made it look really
intriguing
yeah what I mean I don't mind that like
oh thank god yeah because I'm like how
many [ __ ] [ __ ] franchises are we
gonna get we're like like how do people
keep recording what's going on
yeah and granted like it's hard cuz like
we don't have a lot of great examples to
go off of for movies like this cuz I
haven't seen rec to use rec to still
first person it's like I wish I didn't
see rector so rec 3 which was like a
hybrid yeah rec 3 did kind of break out
of that and that's probably the best
example cuz you know like people didn't
really like Blair Witch to or the Last
Exorcism to but like I do think
generally that changing
the visual format is not a bad idea it's
hard to win with that concept you know
like the paranormal movies people are
like that's like you got a little
ridiculous yeah especially because
everyone was family hmm and it's like
there's something seriously wrong with
his family tree but looking at this
trailer and it seemed like the visual
style looks really cool John Goodman has
come a long way since rose am very long
I know everyone Brazil associates him
with that show primarily yeah he hasn't
done anything else to prove that he's a
really great dramatic actor every film
is the first film when you're done good
yeah oh then we work in Roseanne that's
all people really know yeah what named
me two other John Goodman film no one
could think about one good John Goodman
performance outside of Rose ever
no but seriously John John he looks
[ __ ] awesome in this jump it was
great cool Jim getting a lead role as
like a terrifying date in a lot of ways
I can't tell if he's scary but he seems
like kind of scary if all goes well this
seems like a role that he will be able
to have a lot of fun with but still also
be able to be like he's carrying Mary
Elizabeth Winstead I think it's a good
actress um John Goodman's a good actor I
think that you could have a really neat
little trio here well yeah yeah yeah the
guy was Bill Paxton that's not true
yes Bill Paxton he was really annoyed
and this trailer also did the thing I
was hoping that a JJ Abrams produced
film would do what it has intrigued me
it has made it mysterious yeah and it
makes me go I want to see more and I
want to watch it granted don't know
exactly what's going on but I still
really want to watch it yeah which is
what every trailer ought to do yeah I
mean he doesn't necessarily have to be
mysterious if it's not that kind of
movie but every trailer should intrigue
you and give you just a sense for what
might be John Jay knows how to market
yeah you done well cuz Jay Chino is like
it's so it's a simple thing like I mean
he does have like some some skilled
crafting going on but like he seems to
respect the simple idea that if you
don't show us everything we'll want to
go see a movie and then it's like even
does that with movies that might not be
the most complicated or most mysterious
but like
super 8 and he's still kept on edge to
the secret kept it a secret you watch it
you're like it's not like this huge like
oh my god and Cloverfield to was just
like this is a monster film yeah you
know but he knows how to [ __ ] hook
you without showing you much whole
different set of crew here like with
writers and director something kind of
that questions this for me
the people who wrote it and directed it
they're not really known which is fine
you know like a lot of time doesn't mean
it's gonna be dad but we don't have a
previous track record of what they've
done that a lot of us are well aware of
well here's and the other cold on hold
on point not yet finished J bait jaebaek
J pain I bid JJ Abrams has been so busy
with other stuff yeah cuz even Star Trek
3 says like from producer JJ Abrams Jay
Jonah a bruh and when this producer JJ
Abrams well I'm like how much of an
involvement did he have in this
particular one as an own the first
Cloverfield he was heavily involved I
don't know why and you also had there's
been so [ __ ] busy like how involved
is he and yeah they had Drew Goddard on
in that Reeves and like but then again
like those guys weren't exactly
exceptionally well known yet either Matt
Reeves haven't done anything big before
Cloverfield I don't think but he done
some stuff like he'd had some TV and
some some other things under his belt
and then afterwards they'd let me in doc
pota
see the two writers and the two story
credits here one of them is an editor
and one of them most of his prominent
film credits are from producing Damien
Chazelle
orsha zaiah and I'm not sure how his
name is pronounced did whiplash
oh good uh so while this doesn't like
cuz it's not the kind of movie artist
expect him to make like it's a little
weird but I okay lashes really what read
what it says end by him and that usually
means other people wrote it and they
were like we're gonna hire you to touch
it up and ya know he's come in and punch
this up and tighten it yeah exactly
work a little better yeah and then put
your
Peyman there is credit because it'll you
know market that means though it's like
from the people with the track record
that we know of that are involved I
wonder how much of an involvement they
actually had still film looks [ __ ]
intriguing film looks really cool
performances look intense it it has a
totally different tone and vibe from
this trailer at least than what the
first Cloverfield offered yeah which is
rad which I like cuz if it's a monster
movie which it looks like it'll turn
into it'll still be a monster movie yeah
and I feel like if they did a part three
I would like that to be a different
genre - yeah a different horror genre is
this looks like a horror film yeah like
a sci-fi horror movie but but
Cloverfield is a sci-fi horror movie I
mean it's still sick yeah it is but it's
still monster coming to kill you but
just in a sci-fi con but it feels like
this feels like a more like I don't know
like more of eerie if it's more Selam
enough yeah yeah foreboding yeah exactly
it does it doesn't feel as let's go to
the theaters watch the yeah it doesn't
feel as much like booth thrills it yeah
it doesn't feel so much like a roller
coaster as it does like you know a
suspense 'full cuz the first Kluber
filled trailer was like rat a party then
they go outside and all this chaos is
happening and like they didn't even show
us what's happening outside yeah it was
clever with the title like remember
Cloverfield oh that's what's going on
outside yeah yeah it's like and and now
it leaves you to wonder like what is the
world like and also much later is this
taking yes later is this taking place
before and then the event happens I
don't think there's any way this was
just like place Tanglers before the
event not you know simple and and then
they're predicting the future of the
maybe John Goodman like found a
spaceship no one believed him and then
now he's like oh my god this is right
and he's got to fly his point into the
center of the mothership blow it up to
save the day you know Smith and his kids
gotta go home happy believe totally it's
the it's that plot yeah yeah men in
black pursued listen um
gentlemen and ladies
my name is Ryan right this is cherry I'm
cherry what you guys can do is subscribe
today become a reject we're very
welcoming here we welcome all
ethnicities all sexualities straight gay
no bisexuals though make a [ __ ]
choice no it's horrible we're fine
bisexuals two reasons the GRE is a
playlist on this channel reject bins
featuring Jerry and he has dank ass dubs
podcast hosted by Jerry and we don't
have time for a shout-out but start
posting regularly on Tuesday again I'll
be more consistent and you know we have
a lot of things in the pipeline and
saying that lately but trust me things
are really being implemented now it's
why I haven't been posting as regularly
and a lot of meetings and stuff and
let's just say it's gonna get really
exciting around here porn what porn know
what a lot of pool you didn't tell me
about that just let you guys know if
there's any kids out there who watch
this channel don't watch porn hey yeah
it's probably advisable that you refrain
anything a jokes coming here I mean I
probably fine I'm not gonna make a joke
kids don't watch porn it [ __ ] my brain
up watching him when I was young go [ __ ]
yours up to it wait till you're older I
mean a little more equipped to deal with
such a legal age is 18 I know my whole
life that you have to be 18 to go to a
strip club and honestly like if I went
to a strip club earlier than like 20 I
probably would have reacted totally
different than when I went in there now
you know nature which is like whatever
yeah this is a message brought to you by
right wait till you're 18 to go to strip
clubs and watch bar